many of us spent of 2015 adjusting our
expectations accordingly as game after
game got delayed luckily it's now 2016
which means a bunch of those games are
actually coming out probably personally
I'm a little peeved about not getting
the Legend of Zelda for Wii U last yes
since a big chunk of the reason I
decided to fork out 400 stray Lea
dollars for a Wii U was to play that
game while it's awesome that there's a
new 3d open well zelda around the corner
we have been waiting on this one for
three years now 2013 was the first time
we heard a new Legend of Zelda game was
in development but it was until III of
2014 that we saw the first gameplay
footage and we've mostly just been
sitting tight since then on March 27 of
last year producer Eiji Aonuma
announced in a video that the game would
be delayed to 2016 saying our priority
is to make it the ultimate and most
complete Zelda game Nintendo Shigeru
Miyamoto did assure gamers the game is
still set to arrive on the Wii U even
though Nintendo's new console the NX is
nearing release if you spend much time
on websites like GameSpot which I'm
hoping you do you will have had a hard
time missing out on all of the uncharted
4 shadow uncharted 4 a thief's end is
due to mark the well end of nathan drake
saga
we gotta teeth the trailer just before
the end of 2013 and in 2014 it was
announced that The Last of Us
co-directors neil druckmann
and bruce braley would head up the
project going forward at that time the
release window was placed sometime in
2015 that was then shifted to March 18
of 2016 and then to April 26 exactly
what the end might entail for Drake is
still unknown but we do know he'll be
exploring the brave new world of dialog
options which will be a kind of neat or
be needlessly shoehorned in your choice
homefront the Revolution was another one
of those games where the developers knew
way ahead of time that they're slated
release date just wasn't up
pan out home front sequel won't be
continuing the story or style of
gameplay from the original game
according to developer damn busted
Studios damn buster is the game's
current developer after prior developer
chaos studios as parent company THQ sold
off the game trademark when they went
bankrupt the revolution takes place four
years after the events of the original
occupation and follows a resistance
movement against the former North Korean
army occupation of Philadelphia in March
of last year the game was delayed into
this year in order to give the team a
quote every opportunity to turn it into
a best-selling title a closed beta for
the open-world FPS is due on Xbox one in
February while the game will hopefully
hit shelves on may 17 PC strategy fans
would be glad to hear that after a long
wait XCOM 2 is now well and truly on the
horizon just a few weeks off in fact
this one the beginning all kinds of
positive press from early previews throw
the announcement of a delay in August of
2015 which pushed the game back to
February 5 of 2016 was a bit of a blow
for access claimed they needed more time
to polish the game before release XCOM 2
will let you take on aliens with a more
customizable team and introduced new
combat features which emphasize
small-scale guerrilla tactics
since the narrative picks up after
mankind was defeated by the legs of
alien foes at the end of XCOM 1 finally
after suffering what must be close to
watchdogs levels of unachievable hype
we've got Tom Clancy's the division the
MMO shooter charmed loads of people at
Ubisoft e3 press conference in 2013 it
takes place in New York after a pandemic
led to widespread disease and panic your
job as part of this strategic homeland
division is to combat the threat to
brought about by the outbreak and
attempt to piece the city back together
the division was originally due out in
2014 but in May of 2014 that was pushed
to 2015 and almost exactly one year
later Ubisoft announced that they were
delaying the game again until
20:16 the full release is now June on
March 8 but you'll be able to get your
hands on the also delayed beta early
this year let me know down in that
comment section what delay the game
you're excited to play this year and
thank you so much for all your comments
on last week's Geist video we are
changing up the format a little bit this
season so be sure to let me know what
you think of it and we'll see you again
next week